last year just did a huge transformation
lost about 35 kilos i think it's been
really good rebel wilson is getting
candid about her 77 pound weight loss
smash that while appearing on australian
morning show sunrise the 41 year old
actress revealed how her life changed
after losing the weight it's changed
like
dramatically i think um yeah i was going
through a fertility journey and it was
better if i was healthier and i kind of
wanted to to be healthier anyway i
struggled a lot with emotional eating
and i went to the doctors and got my
yearly checkup last week and he's like
oh my god all your labs and your blood
work is like the best it's ever been
rubble dub 2020 her year of health yeah
i'm good this year i'm concentrating on
health but yeah it's the year of health
for me
so it's a slow it's a journey
but no i feel good and the pitch perfect
star documented her journey on social
media sharing her progress with fans
along the way you know it's kind of
remarkable so i i don't know i'm proud
of myself for doing it and also
maintaining it this year even though now
i'm back to work filming movies and just
finished two movies back to back here
and so like but but i'm proud of myself
for like yeah um improving my life for
the better fast forward to 2021 rebel is
opening up about how losing nearly 80
pounds even changed her work life in
unexpected ways their work went up and
she like 16 hour days and my feet would
get like really sore and i'd have to
like like kind of lie upside down and
put my feet up on the couch at the end
of a big day at work and then now i
don't have that kind of thing happening
so so yeah there's definitely end with
jet lag as well i used to suffer a lot
from jet lag
and then now i'm like it's like much
easier to do it in july rebel opened up
on instagram live about what motivated
her to get healthy
it first started when i was like going
through
looking into fertility stuff and the
doctor was like well you have a much
better chance if you were healthier and
so that's kind of what started that if
i'd you know lost some excess weight
that it would give give me a better
chance for freezing eggs and having the
eggs be a better quality so that's what
at first it wasn't even really myself it
was more thinking
of a future
mini me really
[Music]
you